emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine
avait à peine raccroché que la
diplomatie américaine par
l'intermédiaire cette fois non plus dans
tony blinken mais de joe biden lui même
annoncé un nouveau développement dans le
conflit politico-militaire qui n'en
finit plus de rebondir autour du dossier
ukrainien ici à washington il n'est plus
tellement permis d'y voir un hasard mais
pas non plus forcément une action
concertée et coordonnée entre la
diplomatie européenne et américaine en
l'occurrence il s'agit cette fois de
l'annoncé par le président américain
d'un déploiement de soldats de l'us army
en europe de l'est mais il s'agit
surtout d'un point de vue purement
diplomatique de ne pas laisser trop
longtemps les initiatives à la
diplomatie européenne dans le cadre d'un
dialogue qui exclurait cette fois les
amériques durant les premiers mois de la
crise il a beaucoup été dit que les
partenaires européens étaient
spectateurs d'un conflit qui s'annonçait
pourtant dans leur zone de
responsabilité un état de fait qui
convenait d'ailleurs parfaitement à
washington et à moscou jusqu'à ce que le
fameux format normandie capte à nouveau
l'attention de vladimir poutine jusqu'à
faire naître l'hypothèse que les
européens pourraient non seulement
participer au dialogue mais pourquoi pas
conduire par leurs actions à une forme
de résolution ou de désescalade dans la
crise alors bien sûr on pourrait penser
que washington ait d'abord préoccupés
par l'indispensable apaisement qui
éviterait la guerre mais plusieurs
indices montrent néanmoins que joe biden
n'est pas du tout prêt à renoncer à sa
posture de président américain tout
puissant en clair vladimir poutine l'a
compris la diplomatie européenne s'est
engouffré dans la brèche et même si de
part et d'autre de l'atlantique les
chefs d'état des grandes démocraties
occidentales affiche une posture
diplomatique commune il y aura bien tôt
ou tard à l'issue de cette crise un camp
qui pourra plus ou moins revendiqué être
à l'origine de la désescalade et qui
s'en trouvera donc renforcé